muy bien ahora que ya estás
familiarizado con este diagrama podemos
desarrollar nuestra última fórmula
recuerda que necesitamos una fórmula que
nos indique cómo es veces
de acuerdo a cosas que conocemos como la
distancia focal de la lente el tamaño de
la apertura y la distancia hasta nuestro
objeto la clave para esta fórmula es
tomar en cuenta que existen triángulos
semejantes escondidos en el diagrama
para entender esto simplificamos nuestro
diagrama para mostrar solamente los dos
triángulos que nos interesan observa que
el triángulo abc es semejante al
triángulo a ed esto quiere decir que la
longitud de s dividida entre la longitud
d
es igual a la longitud ave dividida
entre a y llamemos esto la ecuación 1
sabemos que d
es el radio de la apertura pero no
conocemos ave ni
vamos a agregar dos nuevos puntos
efe
esto nos dará dos nuevos triángulos
rectángulos a bf y aeg
que también son semejantes esto quiere
decir que ab dividido entre a y es igual
a efe ha dividido entre a g pero f es
solamente la diferencia entre iii y iv
prima iag es la distancia y así que
podemos convertir esto en ave dividido
entre a e iguala y prima menos y
dividida entre y ahora hagamos esta
misma sustitución en la ecuación 1 lo
que nos da s dividido entre d e iguala y
prima menos y dividido entre y por
último resolvemos bc con lo que
obtenemos nuestra respuesta bc es igual
a depor y prima menos y dividido entre i
tenemos una ecuación para el círculo de
confusión
si lo deseamos también podemos sustituir
a mi prima de la ecuación de la lente
simple para expresar el radio del
círculo de confusión en términos de efe
o y oprima voy a dejar que los cálculos
en este ejercicio final